[Musique]
sur une petite île perdue aux confins de
la mer de chine et de l'océan pacifique
on vénère aujourd'hui cette centenaire
comme une icône vivante à 101 ans anna
chine jours entretient tous les jours
les mandats renier de son jardin
ces deux femmes vivent toutes les deux à
okinawa dans le petit village de génie
à l'autre bout de la terre en californie
et bwise 100 ans prend soin de sa forme
tout comme alys robi 99 ans
en sardaigne giuseppe mourihno continue
à 105 ans de cultiver ses vignes et de
manger son raisin à chaque repas tandis
qu'à bayonne en france odette dallas est
sur le point de fêter ses 102 ans
[Musique]
en quelques décennies les centenaires
sont pas céder nos portes minuscule à
une très grande famille afin de percer
les secrets de la longévité des
chercheurs les étudient aux quatre coins
de la planète
ils veulent comprendre comment ces
hommes et ces femmes qui défie les lois
du temps on fait pour passer le cap du
siècle
ils veulent expliquer pourquoi les
centenaires concentre aujourd'hui sur
eux toutes les interrogations et les
inquiétudes liées aux limites de la vie
et au vieillissement de la population
[Musique]
notre voyage à la découverte du mystère
des centenaires commence au japon sur
l'île d'okinawa la terre des immortels
là où les anciens font l'objet d'un
véritable culte
le japon est à l'heure actuelle le pays
dans le monde où l'on vit le plus vieux
on y compte 40 mille centenaire et neuf
d'entre eux résident dans un petit
village nommé au gmi
[Musique]
à l'entrée de gmi trône une stèle en
pierre on peut y lire
à 80 ans tu es encore un gamin est ici à
90 la faucheuse vient te chercher dit
lui passe son chemin et revient quand
j'aurai vécu au moins un an
[Musique]
ici le temps se dilate il s'étire comme
si les montres et les horloges ne
tournait pas au même rythme que celle du
reste de la planète à jimmy un tiers des
3500 habitants de la commune à plus de
65 ans en 1995
la commune s'est vue décerner le titre
de village mondial de la longévité
depuis 1981 au japon le nombre de
centenaires double tous les 10 ans selon
certains démographes
il pourrait être un million après 2050
mais ici à augy me on ne fait pas que
vivre très vieux ont vieilli tout en
restant vaillant et en bonne santé
nous sommes au mois d'octobre plus
exactement le neuvième jour du neuvième
mois du calendrier lunaire
ce matin tous les membres de la famille
commis sous ycompris ceux qui habitent à
l'étranger sont réunis sous aucun
prétexte
il ne souhaite manquer l'événement qui
se prépare
on verra
obama
elle
aujourd'hui madame comme il soit 97 ans
à okinawa
cet âge marque le passage officiel à
l'état de centenaires selon le
calendrier ancestrale que respecte les
okinawa
on fait tous les 12 ans chaque grande
étape de la vie arrivé au stade final
est un aboutissement
il donne à celui ou celle qu'il atteint
le statut d'icône vivante cette fête
appelée qu'agit maillard la fête des
moulins à vent en japonais dépasse
largement le cadre familial
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toute la journée
madame commission et son cortège vont
défiler dans les rues d'auch gmi et de
plusieurs villages aux alentours lors da
kg maillard toute la population est
associée à la cérémonie
c'est un honneur pour la famille de
mettre en valeur sa centenaire
au cours des échanges avec les
villageois madame commis sous va donner
une partie de sa longévité aux plus
jeunes leur faire partager sa force et
en retour accepté les honneurs et les
félicitations dû à son rang
[Applaudissements]
à
à la fin de la journée
madame commis sous se verra
officiellement remettre un diplôme puis
toute la famille et les amis se
retrouveront pour fêter ensemble la
naissance d'une nouvelle centenaire à
jimmy chaque habitant de plus de 90 ans
fait l'objet d'une attention toute
particulière
tous les gens très âgés sont connus est
suivie chaque mois un planning avec
différentes activités leur est proposé
[Musique]
ces exercices de gymnastique qui ont
lieu quatre fois par semaine c'est
nonagénaire et ses centenaires ne font
pas qu entretenir et fortifier leur
corps il cultive aussi l'art d'être
ensemble
l'art d'être heureux ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour ceux qui ne veulent pas ou ne
peuvent plus sortir la découverte d'un
lot de photos anciennes et une occasion
de prendre de leurs nouvelles
[Musique]
à
yoshiharu miyagi à la charge de veiller
sur les centenaires de son quartier
plusieurs fois par semaine et il se rend
chez un hachis jo une femme âgée de 101
ans que tout le monde a osé me
surnomment alassane
[Musique]
la suite à un braquage aubert mois
sur ce match là bas pour prendre son
temps couvert
hannachi jo est née en 1910 elle est la
plus jeune d'une famille de cinq soeurs
aujourd'hui toutes disparu toute la vie
de cette petite fille d'un seigneur de
la guerre déshonoré par l'annexion
d'okinawa par le japon en 1869 est
marqué par la souffrance et la pauvreté
petite elle passe son temps à cultiver
les chauds puis vient le temps des
grands travaux ordonnés par l'empereur
[Musique]
en 1932 elle donne naissance à son fils
c'est riou
en 1945 la bataille d'okinawa est une
véritable tragédie pour les habitants de
l'île hannachi jo se terrent dans les
montagnes elle subit les combats l'exode
puis la faim dans les camps
d'internement américain sur la liste de
noms du monument de chimie qui commémore
les disparus de la bataille d'okinawa
figurent ceux de tous les membres de la
famille d'un à chaque jour celui de son
mari de ses soeurs de ses parents seule
elle et son fils ont survécu tous les
jours yasutoshi une femme de 95 ans rend
visite à son amie anna shinshô quand
elles se sont rencontrées pour la
première fois un oeil à soues avaient
respectivement 11 et 5 ans
la guerre et les années très dures les
ont punis à tout jamais ensemble
elle perpétue la tradition des moai dans
la culture d'okinawa à moi y est un
groupe d'amis de voisins ou de parents
qui se réunissent régulièrement pour
donner ou recevoir un appui social
affectif et parfois financiers
[Musique]
selon une vaste étude médicale
entamé il ya plus de trente ans par des
chercheurs japonais et américains les
personnes très âgées qui garde une vie
sociale active sont très peu sujette aux
maladies et à la dépression les vieux
zoo qui na waie souffre de cinq fois
moins d'affections cardiaques que les
américains du même âge de moins de
cancers et de pathologies comme la
maladie d'alzheimer depuis 1975
le docteur makoto suu kyi a étudié la
vie d'environ 2500 centenaire d'okinawa
toutes les informations qu'il a
recueillies sont stockées là dans ces
dossiers à coursan j'étudie les
centenaires d'okinawa
depuis maintenant plus de 35 ans ce
matin j'ai effectué sur de très nombreux
examens
j'ai fait des électrocardiogrammes des
prises de sang et dans le sens qu'on
constate c'est que l'ensemble de ces
centaines très peu d'occident a dit qu
environ 50% de moi que les autres
personnes du même âge dans les pays
occidentaux on sait que les radicaux
libres qui sont produits naturellement
par le corps quand il transforme les
aliments en énergie ont un impact
important sur la longévité
bush
ces radicaux libres sont réputés pour
endommager les cellules de notre corps
et un accélérer le vieillissement plus
on consomme de nourriture et plus notre
organisme aux fabriques le régime
alimentaire des habitants d'okinawa
aurait-il un impact sur leur faculté à
vivre très longtemps
quand ils déjeunent ensemble hannachi jo
et son fils se contente d'un repas
frugal composé de légumes de tofu un
fromage de soja locale d'un peu de riz
et d'une petite portion de poisson ou de
viande
[Musique]
anna la capitale d'okinawa elle
chercheurs étudient lui aussi le mystère
de la longévité des centenaires de lille
pour le gérontologue craig wilcox le
régime alimentaire qu'ils ont suivi
toute leur vie est un véritable
laboratoire de médecine préventive
nietzsche la chinoise l'alimentation est
très importante à toutes les étapes de
la vie
c'est ce que l'on peut constater avec la
grande majorité des centenaires
d'okinawa
c'est qu'ils ont suivi toute leur vie un
régime alimentaire vraiment particulier
c'est un régime alimentaire très pauvre
en calories et pourtant assez dense et
nourrissant si c'est une sorte
d'alimentation idéal pour dia vire à au
gmi les anciens du village cultive une
grande partie de ce qu'ils consomment
dans son jardin la diététicienne et
missane fait pousser des goyas une sorte
de concombres local des haricots et des
herbes sauvages des légumes que l'on ne
trouve ici sur aucun marché tous les
jours avec ses produits elle
confectionne des menus pour les clients
de son restaurant
ironie de l'histoire cette façon de
cuisiner est née de la misère pendant
très longtemps les habitants de cette
île n'avait tout simplement pas accès à
une nourriture riche et avait très peu
de sources de cadeaux il cultivait des
patates douces lui manger des légumes
verts soupe ses soupes du tofu des
haricots un peu de poisson fait un peu
de viande
c'est ce qu'il faut manger si on veut
vivre longtemps et en bonne santé c'est
à dire en ayant peu de chances de
contracter des maladies ou les
pathologies rencontrées au cours du
vieillissement
beaucoup de ces éléments sont consommés
sous leur forme la plus naturelle
possible crue ou à peine cuit il offre
une nourriture variée très pauvre en
calories et pourtant nourrissante dans
son restaurant et missane propose bien
plus que des recettes savoureuses
équilibrée elle fait partager à ses
clients un peu du secret des centenaires
d'okinawa
ici on applique à chaque repas le haras
hachey bout ce précepte d'origine
confucéenne signifie manger lentement
jusqu'à ce que son estomac soient
remplis à 80 % puis s'arrêter
pour de nombreux os qui na waie le
arachi bout est une règle de vie une
condition indispensable pour vivre
longtemps et en bonne santé
[Musique]
c'est
notre voyage à oger me touche bientôt à
sa fin
avant notre départ 1h ndjoh tient
absolument à nous faire partager un
secret nous attendons avec elle depuis 6
heures du matin quand son petit fils
arrive en fout
c
depuis sa naissance en chine joe se rend
chaque semaine dans ce jardin
ce petit bout de terre lui a été légué
par son père qui lui même le tenait du
sien
ce jardin c'est sa fierté
celle de sa famille
venir y entretenir ses mandariniers est
indispensable pour elle qui est de plus
en plus fatigués par le poids des ans et
des épreuves
en ce sens nous tous les centenaires que
j'ai rencontré ici à okinawa ont une
sorte de raison d'être
ils ont ce qu'on appelle ici un église
gaye quelque chose
une force qui les pousse à sortir du lit
le matin quand on a 100 ans
chaque nouveau jour est un cadeau il
faut voir les choses comme cela
si on perd lé envie de vivre c'est fini
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui dans l'archipel du
soleil levant il se produit un phénomène
inquiétant
en quelques années les modes de vie ont
radicalement changé
les nouveaux types d'alimentation
multiplie les cas d'obésité et de
diabète les maladies cardiovasculaires
et cérébrales sont en très nette hausse
chez les moins de 65 ans mais les plus
touchés sont ceux qui ont entre 20 et 40
ans et le taux de mortalité de cette
catégorie d'âge augmente
considérablement
aujourd'hui pour la première fois
cohabitent au japon de population très
différentes
il y a d'un côté des gens âgés ceux qui
ont plus de 65 ans qui vont vivre de
plus en plus vieux et de l'autre des
gens plus jeunes qui eux ont une
espérance de vie beaucoup plus courte
[Musique]
si ce mode de vie hamburger oui ce qui
provoque l'obésité se poursuit la
situation pourrait devenir
catastrophique car il pourrait y avoir
un déclin de la longévité dans tout le
pays et c'est là que les centenaires ont
un vrai rôle à jouer
le mode de vie des centenaires on peut
qualifier de traditionnelle est en effet
très bénéfique pour la santé
je pense qu'il faut apprendre aux jeunes
ce mode de vie et la culture des
centenaires d'okinawa tous les niveaux
scolaires à l'école primaire au collège
ou lycée
les centenaires ont quelque chose à nous
apprendre à tous que ce soit au niveau
de cette île mais aussi du japon en
général et même des pays étrangers
[Musique]
les maladies cardiovasculaires et le
diabète touche aujourd'hui un américain
sur dix soit environ 30 millions de
personnes presque deux millions et demi
d'individus en meurent chaque année
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle un américain sur
trois est obèse
cette maladie est devenue la deuxième
cause de mortalité dans le pays
75 % des enfants américains nées après
2000 pourrait vivre moins de 70 ans
en 1975 les états unis occupait la
troisième place du classement de
l'espérance de vie des douze pays les
plus industrialisés de la planète
en 2009 ils sont les derniers
[Musique]
il existe pourtant aux états unis un
endroit où les gens vivent plus vieux
est en bien meilleure santé que
l'ensemble des américains loma linda une
petite ville située à 100 kilomètres de
los angeles compte 20000 habitants
parmi eux on trouve une grande
concentration de personnes âgées de plus
de 90 ans et une dizaine de centenaire
cette extrême longévité n'est pas le
seul point commun des habitants de loma
linda tous font partie de la même
congrégation religieuse
ils sont membres de l'église adventiste
du septième jour qui compte aujourd'hui
de 15 à 20 millions de membres à travers
le monde
né au 19e siècle sous l'impulsion du
pasteur james white et de son épouse la
prédicatrice ellen white cette église de
rites protestant se singularise par son
combat pour le sabbat le repos du samedi
et la promotion d'une doctrine très axée
sur la santé
cette doctrine créé par le docteur john
harvey kellock le futur fondateur des
célèbres céréales établi les bases de
tout un système médical
une manière pour l'église d'attirer de
plus en plus de membres au début du 20e
siècle les adventistes sont présents sur
tous les continents
mais leur siège reste aux états unis où
plusieurs villes dont loma linda en sont
des centres névralgiques
[Musique]
on
comment la doctrine adventiste peut-elle
avoir une influence sur l'espérance de
vie de ses membres
répondre à cette question est le but de
l'équipe du docteur gary fraser il y a
une vingtaine d'années
ce médecin a découvert que les membres
de l'église adventiste vivaient en
moyenne entre 5 et 11 ans de plus que
les autres américains josh ou s'agit-il
du soutien et du réconfort qu'apporte
l'église du fait d'appartenir à une
communauté faire partie d'un groupe
concède après de précédentes études à
une grande importance que ce soit un
club un village ou une église c'est
comme être marié ou ne pas être mariée
surtout pour les hommes
cela a certainement à voir avec le fait
d'être entouré mais il peut aussi s'agir
d'autre chose s'il peut s'agir d'avoir
la foi croire et ainsi d'avoir le
sentiment d'être protégé ce qui
réduirait le stress et l'anxiété
[Musique]
alys robi à 99 ans aujourd'hui veuve
elle vit depuis six ans à la loma linda
valait une institution adventiste qui
accueille les plus âgés d'entre eux
alice a choisi cette religion en 1928
quand elle a rencontré son futur mari un
pasteur depuis sa foi ne l'a plus quitté
lire la bible et la première chose que
je fais dans la journée je me lève tous
les jours à 5 heures du 20 heures
je prie et ensuite pendant une heure je
lis un passage de la bible et lire la
bible c'est très important pour moi
c'est un livre plein de bon sens même
modèle pour vivre s'agit il ya une
phrase d'un texte dans le livre des
proverbes que j'aime et qu'il ya un
temps pour rire
il ya un temps pour se reposer du rire
et moi j'aime car il est aussi une autre
phrase un coeur joyeux est un bon remède
j'aimais beaucoup ce texte j'aime être
joyeuse j'aime rire mais raisonnablement
pas de chaîne sport
[Musique]
alex prend son petit déjeuner tous les
jours vers 6h30
comme beaucoup de fidèles elle est
végétarienne la congrégation a toujours
prôné pour ses membres
un mode de vie sain elle interdit
expressément à ses fidèles de fumée de
consommer de l'alcool de la viande est
d'absorber des boissons caféinées et des
épices
[Musique]
ce
depuis 80 ans chaque matin alice mange
des fruits des céréales et de nombreuses
graines
seule entorse à la doctrine un verre de
lait de soja et une tranche de pain
complet qu'elle s'autorise deux à trois
fois par semaine et d'après gary fraser
cette consommation régulière des mêmes
aliments protégerait les adventistes des
risques de maladies cardiaques et de
certains cancers dont sont victimes
beaucoup d'américains les gens les plus
fervents sont souvent ceux qui sont le
plus végétarien prennent soin de leur
santé car cela fait partie de la
doctrine religieuse sont aussi actifs
physiquement il semblerait que cela les
aide à prendre de bonnes décisions
concernant leur santé
[Rires]
presque cent ans et je prie tous les
jours le seigneur de m'avoir amené
jusqu'à cet âge mais il n'ya pas que la
foi en dieu il ya aussi les préceptes je
suis végétarienne depuis tellement
longtemps maintenant je crois que cela
m'a beaucoup aidé à arriver à cette
année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mua
[Musique]
up with a 100 ans cet ancien vendeur de
bible veuf et père de trois enfants vit
seule chez lui il quitte sa maison
uniquement pour passer du temps avec les
autres fidèles de son église et pour
faire du sport
c'est très important de me maintenir en
forme aux clubs de sport 34 par semaine
c'était je suis aussi un régime
alimentaire strict et je me tiens à
l'écart de certains types d'aliments
paraître je suis végétarien foot je
mange beaucoup de ce que devait manger
dieu d'ailleurs je crois qu'il ya une
relation très étroite entre le fait
d'être chrétien de marcher dans les
traces du christ et la longévité
quand on suit les enseignements que le
seigneur nous donne
qu'est-ce que je 16 les textes disent
qu'il faut vivre cours et par là mais
froid en qui la religion semble leur
permettre de faire des choix à long
terme et de s'éloigner ainsi d'un modèle
de satisfaction immédiate
ceux qui font partie d'une église ont
une plus grande estime de même et cela
leur donne un sentiment de plénitude qui
leur fait du bien
[Musique]
tous les samedis matins et bois il
observe le sabbat et seront à l'office
selon les chercheurs qui les étudient
fréquenté des personnes qui les
confortent dans leurs habitudes de vie
saines est la raison principale qui
permettrait aux adventiste de devenir
plus fréquemment centenaire que les
autres amérique
l'étape suivante de notre voyage à la
découverte du mystère des centenaires
nous emmène en sardaigne
nous sommes au coeur de la province de
noro unitaire montagneuses et isolées du
nord-ouest de l'île alors que partout
ailleurs dans le monde
les centenaires sont majoritairement des
femmes cette région présente la
particularité d'avoir autant de
centenaire de sexe masculin que féminin
c'est de découverte a été faite par le
docteur johnny baisse selon lui c'est
dans le village de villa grande dès que
les sardes vivent le plus longtemps et
en plus grand nombre
il commande des 10 villes grandes et à
et le village de ville a grondé à le
nombre le plus élevé de centenaires de
toutes les communes de sartre
nous avons pu recenser 30 centenaire
dont quatre sont toujours en vie c'est
le nombre le plus élevé de toutes les
communes de sardaigne
donc on peut dire que le village de
villa grande et détient le record de
longévité de sardaigne et probablement
d'euros
elle les 30 centenaire qui repose avec
la grande des sont tous nés entre 1847
et 1907 les plus âgées de femmes ont
vécu jusqu'à 107 ans le plus jeune un
homme est mort à son temps le jour de
son anniversaire
parmi eux il y a dix sept hommes pour
treize femmes
un phénomène que personne n'arrive à
expliquer aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le mode de vie typique mansarde
aurait-il un rôle à jouer
pourrait-il s'agir de l'environnement
pour gianni paissent les pistes à
explorer sont nombreuses et les réponses
se trouvent certainement chez les quatre
centenaires qui vivent ta vie la grande
dès aujourd'hui
[Musique]
e
à 105 ans giuseppe mourihno est le plus
vieux d'entre eux d'abord le morceau de
lame tulsa touch me l'a pas ma femme et
moi nous avons beaucoup travaillé
nous sommes restés ensemble pendant 73
ans 73 ans ensemble et nous avons eu
quatre enfants
j'ai déjà trente quatre arrière petits
enfants léger 86 petits enfants parce
que quand les petits-enfants sont en
couple leurs partenaires deviennent eux
aussi vos petits enfants
nous sommes presque 80 aujourd'hui
l on a fait une grande fête pour les
sens tant de ma femme et toute la
famille et des larmes
on s'était tous réunis le mettais plus
de 75 ans tous
[Musique]
cette offre permet son père mais se
borne à sel a commencé depuis six mois
gianni pèse c'est son assistant rendent
régulièrement visite à monsieur mourine
maintenant tu peux faire les réservistes
a peut être capté les conditions de
l'intégrité de l'hôpital hung de la pub
va bénisse simon la pression mais est un
fait la samp et cosy à la pression de
l'union européenne et les autos qu'une
première ouverture de refus à ce qu'on
recycle avant la fin de la soirée
pastore à quelque 80km ifans et val d'or
non purement et les 200 autres
centenaire sarde que gianni pc
rencontrés depuis le début de son
enquête et attend tous est hébergée
dacquois l'état être berger est un
métier qui demande une activité physique
intense et régulière
pour john épaisse un autre élément joue
un rôle important
l'isolément il a permis de conserver
certaines traditions intacte et
encourager un mode de vie simple et sans
très bénéfique pour vivre vieux et en
bonne santé
[Musique]
en continuant son enquête à la mairie de
ville à ground et gianni ps a fait une
nouvelle découverte encore plus
étonnante que la longévité sarde
elle-même et l'attention portée à 182 a
dit d'audit chez novem bre agus maria
grazia aînés en 1778
c'est la plus ancienne centenaire
recensés à ce jour en sardaigne
cette information est capital elle
prouve que la tradition d'atteindre les
100 ans remonte à plusieurs siècles et
qu'elle pourrait être héréditaire et
monte importante et menacé toute la
storia il est très important d'étudier
l'histoire le passé de la population
l'étude des registres d'état civil est
très utile pour reconstruire les liens
de parenté entre les centres mais il se
pourrait bien que tout ce soit issu
d'une longue lignée de centenaires
selon gianni paissent les sardes
auraient su habilement tirer avantage de
leur histoire particulière et de leur
isolement
ceux qui ont peuplé lille est liée à
environ dix mille ans seraient devenus
des incubateurs génétique amplifiant
certaines de leurs caractéristiques
au fil des générations
[Musique]
aujourd'hui encore 75% des sarts de
descendre directement de la population
originelle de lille et si leur
patrimoine génétique contenait une
prédisposition naturelle favorisant la
longévité
[Musique]
au laboratoire de la new sail située à
une trentaine de kilomètres de vie la
grogne des scientifiques cherchent à
établir la base héréditaire de cette
longévité
depuis un an il étudie 6000 personnes
âgées de 16 à 104 ans qui habite dans
quatre communes des environs
[Musique]
d'après les premiers résultats les
chercheurs ont découvert que la
probabilité qu'un membre de la famille
d'un centenaire le deviennent aussi est
plus élevé d'environ 40% par rapport à
un individu pris au hasard dans la
population
plus de la moitié des centenaires third
ont un frère ou une soeur nonagénaire et
au moins un de leurs parents avec
jusqu'à 90 ans
mais pour le professeur francesco cook
le secret de la longévité third réside
dans le croisement d'un certain nombre
de facteurs idéaux comme le mode de vie
et l'environnement
la génétique ne serait qu'un élément de
l'énigme il n'existe pas de gène de la
longévité
il existe probablement plusieurs gènes
qui donne une prédisposition à vivre
plus longtemps et d'autres gènes qui
d'une façon ou d'une autre
protège des maladies courantes la
longévité est donc une condition qui
réunit un ensemble de gènes favorable
certains sont plus spécifiques à la
longévité
d'autres sont des éléments qui protège
des cause importante de mortalité
comment les centenaires ont ils fait
pour atteindre cette ligne d'arrivée
symbolique au terme du marathon d'une
vie tout s'est il joué dès les premiers
kilomètres du parcours ou au contraire
la fin de la course
quand l'ensemble des autres coureurs a
déclaré forfait
philippe amouyel directeur de l'unité de
recherche en santé publique à l'institut
pasteur de lille considère que les
centenaires sont un exemple idéal de
vieillissement
ils n'ont pas ou très peu développé les
maladies généralement associé aux grands
âges parmi elles la maladie d'alzheimer
les gens qui viennent centenaire ne
devienne jamais par hasard pour vivre
longtemps
il ya deux éléments qui sont importants
vous savez que c'est à la fois notre
terrain génétique et nos comportements
qui sont à l'origine de la plupart des
maladies aujourd'hui ces éléments
génétiques qui définissent notre terrain
n'ont de sens que par rapport à
l'environnement dans lequel on vit ainsi
un gène de prédisposition à une maladie
donnée
si nous mettons en oeuvre un certain
nombre de mesures d'environnement
destiné à contrebalancer son effet ne
s'exprimera pas ils vous ne ferez pas
cette maladie
inversement si vous ne savez pas que
vous avez ce gène que vous avez un
comportement qu'on qualifie de à risque
à ce moment là vous aurez plus de risque
malheureusement de développer cette
maladie
[Musique]
parmi ces jeunes il y en a un qui
intéresse particulièrement les
chercheurs son nom la peau et selon la
forme qu'il prend dans le génome la peau
et a une incidence sur la maladie
d'alzheimer
sous une certaine forme et leur montrent
les chances de la développer tandis que
sous une autre il diminue les risques de
la contracter après plusieurs études les
chercheurs ont fait une découverte
étonnante
ils ont constaté que les centenaires
possède beaucoup plus fréquemment la
forme du gène de protection contre la
maladie d'alzheimer
la dernière fois aujourd'hui les équipes
de l'institut pasteur en collaboration
avec d'autres laboratoires
internationaux veulent comparer le
génome de vingt mille patients atteints
de la maladie d'alzheimer à celui de
50000 témoin pris au hasard dans la
population
[Musique]
passion et je pense que dans un mois ou
deux ou peut espérer avoir un
caractériser une dizaine de nouveaux
gènes de la maladie d'alzheimer et tout
le travail aujourd'hui consiste à
comprendre quel est ce terrain génétique
pourquoi parce que essentiellement à
partir de ces nouveaux gènes on trouve
de nouvelles hypothèses et quand on a
des hypothèses on peut chercher les
médicaments
on peut chercher des traitements on peut
chercher de nouveaux outils pour lutter
contre cette maladie grâce à la
génétique sera-t-il possible pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité de lutter contre l'influencé
négative de certains gènes et de
reprogrammer la durée de la vie
en matière de longévité la recherche
animale donne déjà des résultats
spectaculaires au cnrs de toulouse
le biologiste éric le bour augmente
jusqu'à 20% la durée de vie de mouches
en les soumettant à des changements de
température ou de gravité vivre plus
longtemps grâce à la science
un rêve pour certains un cauchemar pour
d'autres
[Musique]
le but de la recherche au vieillissement
c'est pas d'obtenir que les gens en
ville 120 130 ou 140 ans en laine des
tombes ce soit possible ce que je ne
crois pas c'est d'obtenir que les gens
vivent le plus longtemps possible dans
le meilleur état de santé possible
si demain toutes les personnes qui
vivent autour de nous vivait admettons
90 ans et d'un vécu qu'une période
extrêmement brèves de leur vie où ils
sont vraiment très mauvaise santé avant
de mourir ma foi on aurait bien
travaillé si on vit jusqu'à 90 en pleine
forme et puis qu'on meurt d'un seul coup
ou à 95 ans c'est une vie qui valait
vraiment le coup
mais vivre jusqu'à 90 ans en bonne santé
et puis végéter jusqu'à 120 parenti
vraiment en inde en france à bayonne
dans la maison de la famille larcher on
ne craint pas de vieillir
demain enfants petits enfants arrière
petits enfants amis tous vont se
retrouver pour célébrer les cent deux
ans de leur mamie note mamie note c'est
le petit nom d'odette dallas elle est
née à auch le 29 octobre 1908
[Musique]
maribel que je mets demi bijoux tout ce
que je peux pour rester un petit peu
convenable est important parce que c'est
toute la famille qui vient aider à me
voilà
je le vis très occupé en plus je suis
seule à la maison
mais le matin un principe je fais de la
couture il faut que je fasse de la
cuisine l après midi je fais un petit
peu la sieste
par la suite je recommence toujours
quelque chose à faire
[Musique]
je pensais la forme les toujours rue
voilà je les gardais encore ça là je ne
pense pas je n'y pense pas on verra on
verra je n'y pense pas car ça voudra
donc surtout je voudrais rester
indépendante si l'on peut dire quand
même
[Musique]
actuellement pour moi la vie est
beaucoup plus difficile maintenant l'on
peut dire l'ordinateur moi je ne sais
pas faire lors sais pas me servir d'un
ordinateur
alors bon je le maison aof mais je
reçois des factures tout ça payé par
ordinateur moi je suis incapable je veux
pas faire d'efforts non plus pour le
faire à mon âge on a l'habitude
déjà je me suis pas tellement l'habitude
vite au taureau
le fait que le temps dans une famille ne
faisant plus presque de commissions ça
c'est très difficile quand voilà alors
le modernisme
il va vite odette dallas fait partie du
club des centenaires français un club
dont les membres ne cesse d'augmenter au
1er janvier 2010 la france
métropolitaine comptait quinze mille
centenaire c'est aujourd'hui le deuxième
pays au monde où on vit le plus vieux en
1900 il était à peine une centaine dans
l'hexagone y est on y mourrait en
moyenne à 45 ans aujourd'hui grâce à
l'amélioration de l'hygiène des
conditions de travail de l'accès aux
soins
bref des conditions de vie en général
l'espérance de vie est d'environ 79 ans
pour les hommes et 84 pour les femmes la
france après le japon détient le plus
grand nombre de personnes âgées de plus
de 100 points
les rives
[Musique]
le privé leur canton à peine que déjà je
ne sais pas
il est grand temps de se poser avant de
fait aujourd'hui a soufflé ici car c'est
un jour d'hiver aura la 10 e centenaire
certes odette est loin d anniversaire de
son enfance et de la patience qu'elle
avait d'avoir une année de plus mais
entouré des siens
elle profite de chaque seconde et
retrouve la fierté et l'orgueil de
vieillir
[Applaudissements]
de quel temps est réellement aux dettes
comment fait-elle à 102 ans pour
s'inscrire dans une époque à laquelle
elle ne participe presque plus ou alors
de si loin
pour le démographe jean marie robine la
question à laquelle il est urgent de
répondre n'est plus de savoir comment
devenir centenaire
mais que faire quand on le devient la
proportion des personnes âgées au sein
de la population est de plus en plus
grande ça c'est le vieillissement
démographique
mais la grande nouveauté ce qui n'avait
pas du tout été perçu c'est que les
personnes âgées qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses elles mêmes vivent de plus en
plus longtemps et donc rentrer finale
dans une nouvelle tranche de vie qui
nagent et c'est difficile d'en parler on
sait pas est ce qu'on doit parler du
quatrième âge est ce qu'on doit parler
de quoi doit-on parler vivre centenaire
ça jamais été conceptualisée dans aucune
société
rien n'est organisé tout repose sur une
société en trois âges il ya les enfants
à l'école il ya les adultes qui
travaillent et il ya les personnes âgées
qui se passe quelques années en retraite
et là la grande majorité de la
population va vivre demain au delà de 90
ou 200 ans
en 2050 elle pourrait y avoir entre
200000 et 400000 centenaires en france
sommes nous prêts à relever le défi de
la révolution de la longévité qui a
commencé bien aujourd'hui il est urgent
de prendre en compte l'accroissement de
la durée de vie et le vieillissement de
la population pour mieux préparer
l'avenir en collaboration avec d'autres
laboratoires internationaux
l'équipe démographie et santé de
l'inserm l'institut national de la santé
et de la recherche médicale de
montpellier en france travaillent sur
une nouvelle étude afin de mieux
anticiper les conséquences médicales
sociales et économiques de
l'augmentation du nombre de centenaires
pour la première fois les chercheurs
vont tenter de mesurer avec précision
leur état de santé et analyser la
manière dont la société les intègre
trois glissements russie c'est la
personne âgée qui a réussi à conserver
du sens à son existence il ça c'est la
plus grande difficulté quand on a eu
quand on arrivait à un grand âge c'est
d'arriver à continuer à trouver du sens
dans dans sa vie quotidienne
et aujourd'hui si beaucoup de personnes
âgées parce que le taux de suicide on
n'en parle jamais mais le taux de
suicide des personnes âgées de plus de
85 ans est très important en tout c'est
les personnes qui se suicident le plus
aujourd'hui en france donc c'est kaka
mais un vrai problème de qualité de vie
et de sens de la vie au grand âge et ça
vient de ça je pense que le
vieillissement vieillissement qui n'est
pas réussi c'est les gens qui s'ils ont
cette perte de sens c'est-à-dire jeu
sert plus à rien je sers plus rien dans
la société
même si une grande part de leur mystère
demeure les centenaires remettent
aujourd'hui en cause la notion même de
la vieillesse
une notion qui revêtent encore
aujourd'hui de forme celle de la sagesse
symbolisée par la blancheur des cheveux
et celle encore très largement ancrée
dans les esprits de la dégradation
physique et de la déchéance
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en france de nombreuses voix
affirment que des petites filles sur
deux nés après 2005 deviendra centenaire
cette hypothèse se vérifiera peut-être
si l'espérance de vie continue de
progresser
est ce réellement souhaitable certains
centenaires nous prouve qu'il est
possible de bien vieillir
à ce titre ils sont précieux car ils
sont les premiers à expérimenter un
siècle de vie dans une société moderne
ce sont les précurseurs les pionniers
d'une révolution dans nos petits enfants
et nos enfants seront demain les
principaux acteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]